hello and welcome to this video playing
Sheila from turkey before that the
shocker so so the Rollo pass exchange
what is Sheila playing this one okay
yeah i'm not i'm not very knowledgeable
here i think this is the way it is play
but don't ask me for details 96 I think
and then d for that is the line can I
can I do something else there well it's
what is happening if it's a play like
winter you want I mean I'm just
inventing this here I have no idea see
here's to take it huh or not
otherwise bishop no one I can still do
it huh is that such a bad move let's see
I think defies right but I just don't
know the details aha okay
after the current rate I definitely have
a good ending that way okay a little bit
better ending maybe just screen to have
sex I mean look some looks almost forced
maybe you can retreat the bishop like
Bishop 6 yeah and he did it so let's see
for a techie five yeah I thought that
this ending should be pretty okay right
this this bishop doesn't look all that
great good night that should be three
here watch this double now I'm doubling
look I'm doubling of course
yes some forms of dark squid
particularly at fall this is why i'm
thinking i could be slightly better here
right here and doesn't to wait what is
he doing
[Music]
this is a little bit annoying 96 and 95
yeah yeah if not g6 and therefore is
hanging so I'm taking this with a check
and then what okay I can take first and
now figure it out what the best squares
I can also go g3 in this position the
key takes I'm going to play whoop d7 g 3
them plus possibility five
maybe I'm just I'm just retreating this
if it takes a look the seven should be
fine ok now I can also check here King
are no doesn't delete anywhere so let's
go to the seven the King looks it looks
a little bit like there might be some
chick mating ideas here doesn't have
many squares there for the king
okay so i think i'm grabbing on well how
do I have something chick meeting some
chick made ideas check that doesn't do
much okay I'm taking I'm not giving
anything up by taking I think yeah watch
just this 66 pawns fix upon h 5 so look
here would threaten ig3 can also check
your detergent doesn't lead to much
check on g3 maybe then he has to go to
your 5s to go to e5 f 1 i'm checking on
85 no that looks good probably hook b6 I
thought yes this is just too much
material I check here ok now kimchi
before you can stay take stuff David I
should win on the other flank
just hope I'm not self trapping the
night that i had would be honey
sometimes really wonder what did i do
here have some real issues here with
this witness is an idea I have no safe
route for this piece back into my camp I
might just lose it some believe f3 was
was totally Joe secure just play
whatever g3 or whatever great
maybe I can build a square I are now at
least it's not trapped why didn't I go
to the six nobody knows would have one
straight away and that should also win
now yeah they often do okay Hannah
hospitals really awful Wow I mean I'm
fairly okay with what I did in this game
I mean I did I don't know the opening so
very likely i'm very likely this is
played differently yeah i'm pretty sure
i cannot take the night this is usually
never working as a bishop I mean on g610
wants Montuna confused so I feel like
this is the line where leg plays Bishop
g6 now or night F for something like
that it's okay well this it cannot be
terrible i believe to injure you want so
we played this took it it took the Queen
and now this looks fairly fairly solid
yeah maybe taking is right yeah when you
have two bishops against two nights the
engine likes black understandable and
two bishops against two knives is good
now yeah well I'm not happy with the
opening
but does this looked okay i think here i
should be slightly better and the engine
it's not agreeing okay maybe after this
degrees even then not but after kini six
yeah yeah 92 and now g7 this each form
yeah okay I can take be seven but I
think this wasn't bad and now this is
just utterly crazy at just 23 now is
possible or after this g3 of course not
x3 i was thinking there was just a quick
mindless movie Alan you think a fix it
on a dark square yeah but this is this
is just did you're saying if I do this
it is just easy now the night returns
and then winning this very easily with
the with two pawns up or you place this
and when you put it easily back into the
game it then H porn ones or I mean it's
not going to be all that difficult i
think and now i'm not sure if I'm even
better probably not this is a pawn my
night is so bad okay I mean the computer
doesn't seem to find a win so it seems i
can i'm not losing the piece which are
feared yeah this is rescue mission of
course ems 96 i could have done that
okay bye now i'm winning again with yeah
3 was really really awful just to
quickly play it yeah the at the ending
is winning who okay thanks for watching